let's start and i actually
i want to start this with a question and
this is a question for you so it's just
an open question there's no
right the wrong answer here
it's just something you can think about
form your own opinion maybe discuss
later but
so
c plus plus is kind of a different
language from many other programming
languages i think
because it doesn't promote any
particular style of programming or
paradigm
in fact even if you go back to the early
90s and you would ask bjornis rusev the
creator of c plus plus
what the language was all about this
used to be his kind of standard answer
so c plus plus is a general purpose
language with a bias towards systems
programming
that is better c
supports state abstraction supports
object-oriented programming and supports
generic programming and this still holds
true today
but it's kind of a problem with this is
that a lot of people
really didn't get it back then and still
don't i think
for example many people say c plus plus
is an object-oriented language and
actually if you listen close to what
bjorn s drewstep says when he describes
c plus plus he never actually says it's
an object-oriented language he says
something like
it's a language that supports an
object-oriented style of programming and
it's a little bit different like the
language has tools within it to write
efficient similar style object-oriented
code and that's great if that fits your
problem well then go ahead and use those
tools so that will help you make a
better program but they are
that's an optional part of c plus plus
you don't need to use it and it's the
same with all these
styles
and of course with every new version of
the c plus plus standard there are
attempts to make
c plus plus more pleasant to work with
in
each of these different styles and there
are new features to try to make
integrate them better you can also
combine them in
interesting ways that are not easy to do
in many other languages
and so something i have noted is that
like with the more recent c plus
standards more and more new features
take inspiration from functional
programming
so that's the question could
could we even claim that with c plus 20
its language also supports function
programming
uh so i don't know i don't know what
bjarna thinks and i don't know like what
you think it's kind of a vague question
because like what's your definition of
function programming
what's the features from function
programming that you think are essential
in a functional language
so yeah
it's it's a little bit difficult but
that's what i want to kind of explore
here
and uh
so what is functional programming then
well
i i'm sorry i don't have like a clear
definition to me
it it's more like i think of it as a
collection of ideas
and so here are some of the
ideas i think are important it's not all
of the ideas of course but
so first of all in functional
programming
usually you tend to work with immutable
data right so constants
which has many advantages often
constants much easier to reason about in
the code it's great if you want to write
parallel code right if you want to share
data across multiple threads
if it's immutable you don't have to have
any locking mechanisms you don't get any
race
conditions and stuff like that so it's
also great for performance so i guess
that's one reason why functional
programming is
really popular these days
so another idea is that
when we say function functions in
functional programming it's
you usually mean pure functions
meaning first of all functions that are
equality preserving meaning that
if you call a function multiple times
with the same data you always get the
same result back
and
also there should be
there should be no side effects at least
not any side effects that you can
observe externally
so essentially you want to think about
functions like functions in math does it
like a static mapping from inputs to
outputs
and you can cache function calls and so
on
and third idea is
so functions in a functional language
are kind of first class citizens of the
language they are objects also that you
can pass around
as inputs to functions and you can make
functions return new functions
so those are called higher order
functions
and lambda certainly help
in that area
makes functions composable
very important
and then often in function programming
you're also not allowed to use
to write like multi-statement functions
with
variables and so on so
if you want to do something iteratively
if you do you can write a loop you have
to use recursion which can be
difficult sometimes
and the final idea here is
perhaps the least familiar to c plus
programmers a partial function
application which is
if you have a function with certain
number of arguments you don't have to
call it with all the arguments you can
pass just a few of them and what you get
back instead of a normal
response you get back a new function
which
when you call that with the remaining
arguments you get the original function
called so if you're familiar with
something like standard bind
this is the same idea
we'll get back to that later
and of course there are many many
popular programming languages that have
made these kind of features
core features of the language
so
i have a few of them here uh just
curious like how many of you have used
any of these languages and you recognize
them
a few
people yeah
yes
so
you know this one it's closure yeah
this is uh elixir
uh elm erlang f sharp
haskell kotlin scala
so now you know some logos uh and of
course
the third one uh it's called elm
yeah
so you might have heard about these
languages
and they are very different languages
like they are
specialized for different things some of
them are more pure functional some allow
different styles and so on but you have
a good selection of this
and i don't think many people would put
c plus plus in a list like this right
but uh
that's what i kind of want to explore so
i was interested in seeing like could i
use modern c plus plus c plus 20 to
write some code to write a program
that
can artificially limit myself to pure
functional programming and so that the
code would be easy to basically
translate to any of these languages
uh just to see
you know it's it's not keep in mind it's
not
necessarily a good use of c plus plus
it's a test limits of the language and
to do that in a good way i needed uh
a good problem something that's
practical not too theoretical and not
too simple something that you might
actually use for something yeah
uh for something real so uh
so here i got some inspiration from a
youtube video uh
how many of you know about the computer
file channel have you watched it yeah
i'm not surprised like a lot of people
here have seen
this channel it's hugely popular it's i
checked it's past 2.1 million
subscribers so for his channel about
computer science and programming that's
kind of awesome i think
so the format of the channel is usually
like 10 to 20 minutes
interviews with various computer
scientists that talk about something
they're passionate about in computer
computing and uh
yeah it's fun to watch it's like very
easy to
to
get a glimpse into to what they're
working on and even if you're not a
programmer
so this guy is on the channel sometimes
uh
so his name is graham hutton he's a
professor of computer science at
nottingham university
i think he's kind of famous in the
haskell community he's written some
important papers on haskell and
he is also author of this book which is
actually a great book if you want to
learn some haskell programming i think
this is a great starting point
so in this video what he was doing he
was showing
how to use haskell to write a
program that could simultaneously
parse and evaluate mathematical
expressions
uh symbols as strings
in in just a few lines so very beautiful
looking codes i thought this was really
really cool example of functional
programming used to do something
interesting so
but there was a big problem and the
problem was he was using haskell
and i don't know about you but yeah i
know a little bit about haskell i'm kind
of curious but i never actually written
real haskell code so i felt that to
really understand what was going on i
needed to sort of write this in c plus
and see how it would
work in c plus if i could write
something similar and compare it so
that's what i set out to do
so here's a problem
that we're going to try to solve so
so the idea of a parser
is that so we have a string like this
simple mathematical expression with the
multiplication addition and parenthesis
that's all we're going to take as input
to function a parser
that should compute a value like 14 in
this case
and to do that correctly of course it's
not enough to go like from left left to
right to organize this because we want
to respect this convention in math that
we do multiplications before additions
uh unless there are parenthesis
so you can think of this as
yeah the parser should understand this
as a binary tree right where the leaves
are the numbers and these binary
operators have to be applied in order
uh
okay so
before we can write the parser we have
to sort of grasp this this uh syntactic
structure and that's usually done in
some form of a language to describe it
usually some form of uh extended bacchus
in our form
and it can look like this
so this particular syntax was
this is the original extended bucket
snort form uh
invented by nicholas vert he proposed
this in a short article in
communications the acm in the 70s
you should all know about nicolas weird
of course
during award winner creator pascal and
many other great languages
he's written many great books
he's still alive by the way i checked
his
like last tuesday he turned eight to
eight
so still going strong and uh
he
um
yeah so so
here here is a little grammar that
explains how we should do the parsing so
you sort of read these grammars from the
top to the bottom so at first we have
expert that's the whole expression and
that consists of a term followed by
a plus sign followed by another
expression or it could be just a term so
quotes means it's a string literal
and the pipe character is his choice
so with that with just that rule you can
see you can recursively describe the
whole
expression as finite sum of terms so
then we parse the terms the second rule
so that's the same thing but yeah it's a
factor a multiplication is a term or a
factor
so since this rule comes below that will
give us like the we do the
multiplications before the additions
and then we have a factor which is
either a parenthesized expression so
this is like going back to the top
which will allow you to override the
evaluation order
or it's an integer
and then we have an integer
that could be a negative number so
optionally there's a minus sign right
so square brackets means zero one or
whatever oh what's inside
followed by a digit followed by more
digits so
yeah the killer braces is a loop
and then of course it did this could be
end of the 10 digit symbol so this is a
nice little
grammar that describes this language
so now the problem is we just need to
take this and write a parser for based
on this
and of course there are many
ways to write parsers
so i'm just going to talk about two
here
so one thing one approach you can use is
you can use a parser generator and
that's just a tool it's actually a
parser itself so it can parse grammars
and turn them into source code for the
parser that in your favorite language
it's not all the code like you have to
add the types of the things you want to
parse and so on but you'll get most of
the up done
and then you just compile it and you
have a parser right
so another approach if you don't want to
use a tool if you want to actually start
from scratch
so one approach that works great with
functional languages is
to write a parser combinator and that's
the kind of parser that i'm going to
talk about
so
parser combinator you you just write
functions and it's there's two kind of
functions
uh
the first kind is just players called
parsers
and they can be you start by writing
very very trivial parsers so like they
don't parse the entire input they just
parse maybe a single character
so you
start very simple
and then you need to write a few
generic higher order functions these are
functions called parser combinators
because they you can take multiple
parsers combine them in different ways
into more advanced parsers and you just
need a few of those
to do some
generic stuff and then you can sort of
build up more and more advanced parsers
from those as your basic building blocks
until you can parse this
rules of your grammar
right so
let's look at the first kind here the
parsers
what should a parsley look like
so
so this is basic idea parser is the
function that takes a string
and since we work with immutable data
here we can use standard string view
that's a great type has a great
interface for this
and it should return a parsed thing of
whatever type
t you like it depends on what you're
parsing right if you're parsing a number
maybe just want a numeric type if you
parse a
identifier maybe you want a string if
you parse an entire programming language
you maybe want some kind of abstract
syntax tree some
data structure that you you know pass on
to the
next stages in the compiler so
uh so that's a basic idea here but it's
a little too simple
first of all
like the parser shouldn't
except on the top level the parsers
don't parse all of the input so we have
to
describe somehow
how much of the input we have parsed and
what is left over for the next parser
and so very simple solution is we
instead of returning a thing we can
return a standard pair of the pars thing
and the string view whatever's left over
but there's one more thing to fix and
the second thing is
if
what happens if the parsing fails what
if you give it a bad input
right what should you do how do you
signal an error
so there are multiple solutions the one
i have chosen here is one of the
simplest ones
and yeah
common one instead of returning a pair
we can return as the optional pair so we
just wrap that pair instead optional
so we get that extra empty state which
can represent the parsing has failed
so there's no information why it failed
we don't particularly care here
just to keep things simple
and note also that there's no assumption
about how often we're going to fail in
reality it's going to be quite a common
and natural thing to fail
so this is actually perfect first
optional just the kind of things that
optional
is designed for
okay so that's the actual
function signature of parser there's
just one thing i don't really like here
and it's very long return type and the
only thing that varies is the type of
the thing right
so we can make it a little bit shorter
with an alias
so if we just define an alias template
uh which are called parse t so t for
type
uh it's a little easier to read
and note that of course and it's just an
alias it's not a new type or anything is
just a different name for the same type
i kind of prefer to view this in a more
functional way so i prefer to view it as
an example of type constructor
so what's that well uh you hear about
type constructors a lot in haskell
actually a typo it's very simple it's
just what it sounds like it's some kind
of
language mechanism that you use to
construct a new type from existing types
so in a sense you can think of this
parse t ot return type as
you're kind of making a compile time
function called
you're passing in a type and it returns
a new type constructed based on that
so uh and in some sense this alias is
like a function that defines
what that is so stood optional instead
pair are both examples type constructors
in c plus they're not types they're
templates
which you have to
instantiate it with a type and the
compiler gives you a new type from them
so yeah
if you don't see it you don't see it
it's not terribly important but i think
it's interesting that like we're already
doing some functional programming here
at compile time operating on types
but yeah so
how do you remember the function
signature of a parser maybe you've seen
this one before
it's a little nice little rhyme comes
from the haskell community again
uh so a parser of things is a function
from strings or string views
to an optional pair of things and
strings that kind of gives you the
essence right
so i really like that
[Music]
so so really what is a parser is it a
particular type
no because
you know functions have types right but
there are
different functions have different types
so this is like the set of all functions
that have this interface and do parsing
and that's to me that sounds exactly
like the definition of a concept
right so how many of you have used c
plus concepts so far like for real yeah
a few people there really good concept
is my favorite feature from z plus plus
20 and
the best
kind of high level description i know is
in this book from mathematics to generic
programming
which says a concept can be viewed as a
set of requirements and types or as a
predicate that tests whether types meet
those requirements
and the requirements concern the
operations the titans provide so
interface of a type
but also their semantics
what they do and their time is based
complexity a type is set to satisfy a
concept if it meets these requirements
so
something to notice that the type is not
aware in any way that it satisfies a
concept it's
implicitly satisfies a concept by having
the required interface as part of its
interface
and behaving in the right way
which is actually great because if you
think about so you can define a concept
and it will be satisfied by types that
you already had you don't have to like
been inheritance
explicitly state that it inherits from
something here you can
even write a concept that describe a
built-in type or standard library type
or third-party library type that you use
that you cannot change
and also the c plus plus 20 standard
comes with a bunch of
library types defined that we can use
for
for basic things and in a standard
they're just described as
components that c plus programs may use
to perform compile time validation of
template arguments before function
dispatch based on properties of types so
that's kind of doesn't explain anything
about concepts it just tells you
something what you can use them for
so
with c plus plus 20 we got this as a
core language feature instead of just
describing it in documentation we can
actually
do some type checking at compile time
and i'm going to use a few of the
standard library concepts all in all i'm
just going to use five
and i'm only going to talk about two
here
so the first concept
is called standard same as this is the
first concept in the standard very
simple
so
you can probably guess just from the
name but it does it checks if two types
are exactly the same so if you put
standard same as int since into the same
type as in this will be
at compile time the value true so you
could do a static search like that
and in the double since there are
different types that would be false and
that would fail to compile
of course in real code you wouldn't have
a silly check like that but you might
have a check if you
if you use an alias or something
depending on template parameter then it
could be useful
the second concept i'm using is very
important for functional programming
so it's called regular invokable
and uh
perhaps that name is a little bit
confusing uh but it helps to think of
that as
meaning pure function
basically so
it's a very added concept it takes
at first it takes a type of function or
a presumed function like a to i for
example
and then it takes the types of its
arguments
this is actually quite kind of similar
to what arnold was talking about with
the type traits but now here it is as a
concept instead
you have to be a little bit careful with
this concept though because if you check
a function like rand which takes no
arguments and clearly is not
a pure function
right it has side effects it will still
compile and that's because concepts can
only check syntax so there's a
limitation in the language here that
if you have a function you cannot
somehow annotate it
that it's
if it's a pure function or not and the
concept checks are only on the interface
level
uh
so that's good to know
another thing like why is it called
invokable
why didn't they just call it callable or
function or something like that
so that's related to another problem
with staples plus functions
the problem is there are so many ways
you can define a function in c plus plus
if you think about it right you can make
three functions but you can also have
function pointers they are
also callable standard calls and
callable types
you have
member functions pointers to member
functions you can have pointers to
member data which can be callable in
turn you can have class with a function
call operator
you can have a class that's convertible
to a function pointer you can have class
inheriting from a callable class
you can have lambdas of course
you can have a library component likes
that functions the memphin
the return typos that bind you can have
a reference wrapper 10 of these things
and you can have a template and yeah the
list goes on all of these things yeah
yeah i will i will explain shortly what
it
what it actually checks so
the problem here uh all of these are
callable but unfortunately the syntax to
call them is not always consistent you
cannot just put
name of the thing parentheses arguments
like you call a normal function in some
cases the syntax looks a little bit
different so think about
maybe you know if you have a pointer to
a member function there's a special
query syntax to call that member
function
is that a huge problem well
most of the time maybe not but it
becomes a problem if you write generic
code so if you write a template function
that takes another function as input
like many of standard library algorithms
do that like find if you pass it a
function the predicate that you want to
check
now you end up with the problem inside
the template how do you properly call
that callable thing if the syntax can
vary
now that you can solve either through
some really complicated template meta
programming so you get a lot of code
duplication and miss some obscure edge
case of course
or you can just solve it by passing
everything to standard invoke
which was added in c plus plus
17.
so what's just passive everything and to
see standard invoke and let standard
invoke do the meta programming or
whatever it does to solve that for you
so you get kind of a uniform kind of
ugly syntax but still it makes the code
a lot easier to use so that's why it's
called invokable technically what is
check
is can it pass this to standard invoke
and will it compile
so yeah i hope that
answers your question um
so
okay a lot of stuff here about these
concepts but we actually want to write
our own concepts and with c plus plus 20
here's how you define a concept you
define them as a template you can use
some types
parameters
then using your keyword concept the name
of the concept equals
some compile-time boolean expression and
very lucky for us it turns out the
string literal is
a compile-time boolean expression it's
implicitly convertible to true so
technically to the compiler this is a
valid concept it will compile but it's
kind of a useless concept it's telling
you it's telling the compiler every type
is parser
so that's that's not what we want that's
too unconstrained
so we want to describe it more precisely
we want to translate that little rhyme
into c plus
code and so now we can do this with the
help of our concept so first of all a
parser of things is a function from
strings
so we can express that as it's a regular
invocable
that takes a single argument in our case
of type string view
and what about the return type well it
should be
it should be an optional pair right we
had an a list for that
uh return
that optional pair so one way you can
express this
is with a requires expression
and that's mostly used in just in
definition of concepts so that's the
other new keyword requires
followed by a list of parameters
some curly braces and inside you
basically have compile time statements
that have to be true for this to compile
so
so think of this as you're telling the
compiler please imagine you have an
object called result
what's the type of result well it should
be the return type or our function
or presumed uh
type here or function p
so here i'm using uh invoke result t
like arno showed in the previous talk
that is the return type of this presumed
function
so if we can get that then we just need
to check what that type should be and
here we can use the same as so we we
want the type of that result to be a
parsed t of something
what's the something well it has to be
an optional pair so we can actually
extract the value type out of the
optional that's a pair and then we take
the first type of the pair that's the
thing
so if all of this works out then you
know at least and tactically you have a
parser
okay so it's also helpful to define a
few
type functions and type functions are
these are just aliases again the only
difference from the type constructor
alias is here this is referring to types
that already exist they are just related
to the parser type
so we have the
return type supports i have a result
type which is just there is a shorter
way of writing the return type or invoke
result t
and they have a value type which is the
type of the parsed thing
so
but what's cool here we can these are
templates but now we can constrain them
with our concept so instead of say type
name p i'm saying parser p so if you try
to use this name with an int or
something it will fail to compile
right so that's a lot of new c plus plus
20 stuff
so now let's actually start writing our
parser so here's my first
functional parser
i could have made this as a free
function i just just make it lambda they
are handy sometimes
but yeah it's just function it takes
some input it returns a parsed character
and it's going to be the first character
in the string so it
this could actually fail if you give it
an empty string
we should fail and that we can do with
the return type deduction here because
yeah i have been explicit about the
return type so i can just use the empty
brackets as a default constructed
optional
right it's going to be
what we want
otherwise we can extract the first
character
and we
have parsed the first character so the
rest is the substring starting from the
next character
okay so if you want to you can actually
yeah you can actually check here that
this function
is a parser with static assert i
wouldn't normally do this in real code
but it's
good to know that you can
and we can also make some everything
here's const expert so we can make a
sort of unit test even at compile time
checking that for example if we give the
string foo we should that should parse f
and leave the o's
for the next parser if you give it the
empty string it should fail right
so everything clear
good um
that seems like the simplest thing you
can do but it's actually there's an even
simpler thing you can do you can just
fail
so here's the empty parser it just
takes an input we don't even need to
name it because we're just going to fail
what's interesting about this one is
there's no way to tell even if it's
empty it has to have a type right so
there's not one empty parser this one
empty parser for any conceivable type
you have so you have to call empty and
with a type
so the empty empty char of foo that will
be an empty parse char empty
in the empty string will be
empty in parse to
end okay so
very basic parsers
these are actually going to be the only
parsers we need just to get started
so
let's go to the parser combinators
and so here i'm jumping right into the
concept that describes them
so now i hope you can
read what this does so parsley
combinator is just a function that takes
any number of arguments
can be zero arguments actually
if you want to
and its return type so that invoke
resulti should be a parser
so it doesn't have to actually combine
multiple parsers you can have a
parsley combinator that takes nothing
the important thing is that it returns a
parser
and parsley combinators also have a
value type that i have defined
and here i'm using a requires clause
to check that that's the most general
form of concept
check that you can do
so that's is
different from requires expression it's
just the keyword requires followed by
some compiled time boolean
expression usually a concept
so that's a parser combinator and let's
look at an example
so suppose you want to parse
an input that should start with a
certain string
so then it could be useful to create a
parser for just that particular string
and that we can do this function stir
so it takes
a string v view of the thing you want to
match
uh so it takes a string of this input
but it doesn't return a parsed thing it
returns this lambda so it returns a
parser
which just captures that string you want
to match so that later when you call it
it will just
check if the input starts with that
match that's what we want to see so we
return that successfully otherwise we
fail
so this is using a new feature c plus 20
so standard string and standard string
view got some new member functions in c
plus 20 one of them is starts with which
is perfect this is just what i needed
for this
all right so
for example if you want to parse the
string if you call sturfu you get the
parser that when you parse full bar you
will get the successfully
okay so uh
here's another parser combinator and
this one is really important but also
yeah really basic
the idea here is that suppose you have a
thing any type an object of any type t
and all you want to do is you want to
turn that into a parsed thing without
doing any actual parsing
so we're just returning here a parser
that captures the thing
if you use that later with some input if
you just plug the thing and input
together without actually touching the
input
so for example if you call unit of x you
get back a parser
which makes x the result of whatever you
parse
if you use unit of 42 that will be yeah
you get the parsed in 42
empty string it can actually never fail
because you're not doing any parsing
all right so
this one is
the first parsley combinator that
actually combines two parsers it's
so important that it shows instead of
giving it just a name i overloaded an
operator for this but don't worry about
that
it's just a function that takes two
parsers
and the idea is that we want to try the
first parser
if it
fails we try the second parser
so
so we here's the first use of invoke
because we don't know exactly what kind
of callable
type or p is here so we just call it
withstood invoke
and then since the
result should be an optional pair
remember
optional has an explicit operator bool
so we can use it just in an if statement
to check if it's
empty or not
and if it's not empty we are happy we
have successfully parsed with p
but otherwise we try q
to make this compile i have to
i have to be explicit about the return
type here and i chose to make the return
type of the second parser because of
course these two parsers could return
two different types and that wouldn't
work but it would be okay if the type of
the first parser is convertible to the
type of the second parser and that you
can check with this concept stood
convertible to so that's kind of like
same as so it takes two types
but here it checks if the first type is
convertible to the other
implicitly and explicitly and those two
conversions have to be equivalent that's
a semantic requirement
so then this will work
so also note that since we're returning
a lambda
we cannot say what the return type of
this function is because the types of
lambdas are only accessible to the
compiler we don't have a name for them
so the return type of functions like
this in c plus plus have to be auto
however we can with the concept we can
constrain that auto and say that it
should actually have to be a parser
uh if it's a single argument concept
like parser so this is really nice i
think even if you
uh if you don't specify exactly what
type it is the important thing is that
it's a parser and you can actually
make the code much more readable like
that also if you implement the wrong
thing this would fail to compile
so why is it binary operator well
because it's a binary operation like it
takes two parsers it also returns a
parser so you could actually
string those along if you have multiple
things you want to try
so if you parse
if you combine empty of char with item
and unit of x it's very handy to have an
infix
operator here
and of course what would happen if you
parse empty string well empty of chars
always fails so that's kind of silly to
have there it's just an example
item would also fail in this case
because
there's an empty string so we would end
up just parsing with unit x here
now
i know it's kind of controversial to
overload operators for
exotic things some people really dislike
that and there's many good reasons to
dislike it it could make the code
very terse but also very obscure and
hard to understand so i'm actually not
going to use this directly i just need
it so that i can implement a little
helper function here
and that's a function i call choice
so this is using some other nice c plus
plus 20 features
so it takes a parser and a pack of
parsers
and then i'm using a
fold expression here so it's a binary
left fold
uh
this if you ignore the if constexpr it's
look just look at the stuff inside of
else here what this will do so if you
call it
with just one parser it just returns it
but if you call it with some additional
parsers
it will call my operator passing in
first the parser and the first of the
parsers take the return value pass it in
on the left within the second of the
parsers and so on and so on so it's like
a loop
uh
so this is nice now like you can use
that choice name instead and it becomes
the com operator becomes your in
infix operator
there's also another thing that i
discovered when i implemented this
was when i tested it it failed to
compile when i was passing in just a
free function as the first parser and at
first i didn't understand why but then i
realized
if you're passing in a function
as a template parameter what are you
really passing you're passing a
function pointer right
uh what's a function pointer it's just a
pointer type
and the core language doesn't have the
bitwise operators defined for
function for pointers
that wouldn't make any sense so and we
cannot just override that rule by
implementing our own
so the way i
got around that is with a compile-time
check and if constexpr here so if it is
a pointer then i just wrap that pointer
in a lambda
that does nothing but just call it
when you call it and then it compiles so
those are kind of yeah ugly things you
have to deal with in c plus but it makes
this function more useful
okay so
this part's a combinator this slide i
think is the most important one in this
whole talk so if you miss a lot of other
stuff but you get what this function
does then you
kind of
have grasped some really profound things
in functional programming uh
so this is also a parts combinator that
combines uh combines two parsers
but we're not passing into parsers we're
passing in one parser and a function
so what kind of function well you can
see in the concept it has to be a parser
combinator
and it's part combinator it takes one
argument of the value type of the first
parser
so why are we doing that well
again first we try the parser
then
if it's successful we invoke this
function this parser combinator and we
pass in the parsed thing
and since this is a parser combinator it
will return a parser so this is the
second parser and then we immediately
parse with that one on the rest of the
string
so we are combining two parsers but it's
we're much more being much more smart
than just passing a second part
parser directly we're being lazy about
the choice of the second parser and
since this second parser actually gets
the result from the first parser we can
make this function
incorporate the result of the first
parser if you want to or we can make a
function that chooses what the second
parser should be
based on what the first parser has seen
so that allows you to do some really
cool stuff you can parse
languages that are not
context-free
so this language but the rules change
depending on what you have parsed so
that's really advanced stuff but we're
not going to use it but it's kind of
cool to know that you can't do that
so the simplest example if you parse
item
the item parser and combine it with the
unit of char
parser combinator what would happen so
item would parse
we have fu as inputs item with parse f
the f get passed gets passed in the unit
of jar which gives just gives you the
parser that
gives you f back again
and then we parse with that so we get
the f so actually putting unit of char
here on the right side has no effect
so there's an important relationship
here between this operator and unit of
char
kind of similar to how empty doesn't do
anything on the
with choice
so
i
decided to give this a good name as well
i kind of like the name shane
so you can think of these parsers as
uh kind of links in a chain if any of
these parsers returned by the parse
combinators fails this whole chain of
parsing will fail and we just undo
everything
yeah one thing i forgot to say also note
that this function chain is uh
this is template
but that's another nice thing with c
plus plus 20 now you can
if you have uh
yeah you can use auto parameters now for
functions uh like this
if they are simple so uh
i think that syntax is real nice and you
can see this is called automatic
template deduction
uh and
you can also constrain these
uh auto parameters so this is just like
with the generic lambdas you could write
lambdas with auto since
was the c plus 14 i think
now we can also do this with three
functions
which is really nice
okay
so
yeah
yeah actually yeah that's a good
question why did i constrain funcs i
i didn't come up with a way to actually
do that
since it's a very addict
uh argument i i'm not sure how to do
that but and they are also like the the
types will be
depending on this the return types could
be depending on the function ah
we could talk about later perhaps but
yeah i couldn't find a good way to do it
here
all right so these
choice and chain functions are very
useful together so suppose you want to
write a parser called skip it's almost
exactly like choice
but the idea here is just we parse with
parser p
and then we throw away the result
whether it succeeded or not and return
the result of q
so you could implement that that's very
simple
so if you skip
item and
use unit of x so foo then you would get
x and those right
but now you could also write this as a
one-liner
just combine choice and chain
so the easiest way to
see how this works is imagine that the
first part of p succeeds
so shane with parts with p
the parsed thing goes into this little
lambda which is a parser combinator
which just throws it away and returns
the second part of q
and then we will parse with that
so this is the first branch of the if
if the parser p fails the whole call to
chain fails and then we will the choice
will try the second part of the queue
that's the other branch
so these are really extremely powerful
functions
uh
here's another example suppose you want
to parse a digit just a single digit so
it's just like the item parser except
there's an extra check so if you have a
character
and it's a digit so use this digit here
then it's
successful
so that's easy to write but what if you
want to parse something different maybe
you want to parse
a lowercase letter instead so as you can
imagine you can write that
you take this function you call it lower
and you use a slower
function instead
but then you realize you only parse
upper case letters so you copy this
function you call it upper use a
different predicate
so you start to realize you have a code
duplication right which this is all the
same function it just varies with
predicate
so you might think okay so what if i
make a parser that takes that predicate
as an input and just check it
can you do that
no you can't because then it wouldn't be
a parser anymore a parser has to take a
single argument the input
so you have to write this as a parser
combinator
and maybe it looks a bit scary because
there's two nested lambdas here but i
call it satisfy
so satisfy takes a predicate and a
parser we can even default that to be
the item parser that's the most common
case
and
so what's a predicate well we have also
a concept for that it's just a more
constrained version of regular invocable
so stud predicate means it's a regular
invocable whose return type is boolean
testable so that it could be bool but
the return type doesn't have to
technically be bool it could be a type
that's convertible to bool and it has to
have a
negation operator that whose return type
is also convertible to bool so it's a
bit technical but yeah it's a function
returning a bool you can think of it as
that
so
satisfy what will it do it returns a new
parser using shane
what will this do when we call it it
will first parse with our parser
we get the parse thing passed into this
outer lambda
which is
a parser combinator
then we return a new parser which is
captured the predicate and the thing
and when we parse with that we will
check the predicate on the parse thing
and succeed or fail
so
once you have defined this function
it becomes really trivial to parse
digits because it's just a call to
satisfy with the predicate
and the implicit
single character parser if it parses
lower case satisfy is lower parts
uppercase satisfies upper
what if you have a we're going to parse
letters well letter what is it either a
lowercase or a uppercase
symbol so you can just combine them with
choice
an alphanumeric character that would be
a letter or a digit so here we're
starting to see like with these basic
functions
it becomes very nice declarative code
here that really explains uh you just
need to read it and
you should
see what it does very easily
it's also useful to have
a parser combinator called symbol
so the idea is you just give it a
character and it returns a parser that
checks if it matches that exact
character so you could also write that
and then you can easily if you want to
parse plus you just call it symbol plus
so
okay so
so far we have done some pretty
simple parsing with just
single
things
so
but sometimes you want to parse multiple
things you want to apply a parser
multiple times as many times as you can
without
yeah as many times as you can and then
combine those into one thing
so for this we need iteration and
uh this is a little bit more difficult
this parser i have to define as a class
because there's stuff to capture but we
also need a name for it if we're going
to use recursion we cannot use a lambda
because we need a name for the thing we
we call recursively
but basically it's it's not that
complicated it's just a function again
with a function called operator
so we start reduce many it takes some
initial thing
it takes a parser
and it takes a function
and if you look again at the concept at
the top
the function has to be a function that
takes two arguments the first have to be
the type of the initial thing the second
have to be the type
the value type of the parser
and what we do again we can combine
choice and chain here so when you give
some input
we will first call the parser
we get a parse thing
then we pass that thing together with
the initial thing
into this function so this function can
combine these two
like it's two characters combine them
into a string
and that gives us our new initial thing
and then we can recursively make a new
reduce many parser from that and
uh
so this will effectively this will call
recursively the same parser
concatenating things with our function
until it fails and what happens when it
fails when
the second option of the choice kicks in
and it gives us back the initial thing
which will be the
thing we have combined so far so of
course this would be easier to write as
a loop in c plus plus this isn't
terribly efficient
uh but it's i think it's kind of
interesting to see how you can do this
so there's no state here in this
thing except for a state you start with
in the constructor everything is
constant
and uh yeah so it's it's pretty
interesting
so
we can make a little helper function for
this too
uh
which is special this is just for
character parser so i call that many so
many will
start with an empty string
parts with our character parser and with
this little lambda here the third
argument will concatenate the result
into a string so now we can parse for
example many
many symbol plus
so that will give you a parser that
parses three pluses from the beginning
if there's no pluses we'll get the empty
string
okay so we can parse many things now
that's useful if you want to parse white
space
so white space what is that it's many
satisfy a space
very simple
it's useful if you want to parse tokens
what's a token so it's something we
parse by skipping some white space
applying our parser
and skipping some more white space after
it and then returning the parts thing
so we can use chain here so now we can
parse for example full bar
it will strip the white space before and
after and we just get the full
now sometimes you don't want to parse
the thing zero or more times you want to
parse it one or more times
so we want the same result as with the
with many here but except in the second
case when we have no pluses in the
beginning
we want to fail instead of returning an
empty string so that at first seems
simple so we just need to
first use chain again call our parser we
get the first character then we use many
to call the rest of the
uh the rest of the characters and then
at the end we just need to concatenate
the first character and the rest of the
string
and unfortunately that doesn't work
and i think i hope you can see why it
doesn't work
the problem is we do have the string
from many but we don't have the first
character
that was passed into the previous lambda
which we never used it there we just
threw it away
so it's lost we cannot access it in the
lower lambda so that's a problem with
shea in here
right
if there's just one lamb there's no
problem but if you have multiple ones
you can only access the thing right
above it
so how can we solve that
so my first thought was
maybe we can just make some kind of
smart parser that combines many with the
first character and pass it along
it works but it's not very nice looking
another thing we could do is make this
sum into a class instead so we can have
a private data member we can store that
character so then we can access it later
but that doesn't feel like a functional
solution so it turns out the
general functional solution here is much
more
interesting
all we need to think about is
we don't have this problem if we just
had one lambda so how can we merge these
two lambdas
a simple way to start is just to wrap
them in a new lambda
right
so you just write a new lambda with same
function signature as the first one
and then you're fine with the axis right
you have the character because it's
passed in and then you capture it in the
bottom lambda so it should be accessible
but also it should it won't compile now
we have
we need to return something in this
lambda and we still have the two inner
ones
to combine and we want to call them one
after the other so we only have one
function to do that we have to call
chain again
right
but that doesn't compile either because
shane has the wrong function signature
the first argument to chain has to be a
parser
and now it's a parser combinator oh
that's a problem
but actually when you think about what's
the first thing you want to do here
well you just want to you just want to
call that parser inside there so let's
just remove that first lambda just keep
the return value and now it works
right the character gets passed in
you so you first parse with a parser
then you parse the menu parser you have
capture both things and you it works
great so now
we can parse natural numbers
an at your number it's some digits
one or more digits remember that
but we don't want that as a string we
want it as an in this case so we can use
chain to convert that into an int with
s2i
so now we parse natural numbers
what if we want to parse an integer
what's an integer either it's a natural
number now we have a parser for that or
it's a minus symbol followed by a
natural number and then we just want to
negate it
so
uh here we're also
using two lambdas with a chain so sure
you lose that minus symbol but in this
case it's fine because if we're seeing
the minus we know
what we want to do we just negate our
natural number
okay great so now we can parse integers
and it works
i actually want to
stay a little bit on this
chain function problem
because it's
very important here's another example
suppose you want to parse three integers
with white space
so you just want to apply token integer
three times
and then add them up
so that seems
straightforward to write like the left
version unfortunately it doesn't work
because you just have the last
integer at the end
so what you have to do you have to apply
this trick of combining the last two and
then you get a new lambda and then you
combine that
and you get that code on the right which
actually works it solves the problem if
you have the
captures in the right places
but it comes as a trade-off right
you want to be able to write the code on
the left if you can the code on the
right does multiple calls to shane so
there's some performance
uh
issues there there's extra captures
and of course it looks very ugly to have
this deeply nested code right
you get a whole like trail of sad emojis
at the end
so that's
that's not code you want to write if you
can avoid it
sometimes you can write a bit of a
hybrid between the two and in principle
you could go back and forth it's the
same thing but
the right version is the general one
that always works
so can we do something about the ugly
syntax well
if you're prepared to sheet a little bit
with standard formatting tools and so on
we can sort of rearrange it a bit
so if we just
move things over so the important stuff
is on the left
the the the parsers and the kind of
boilerplate stuff is on the right then
you it becomes easier to kind of see
what we're doing we're
calling this three token integer we call
the result x y and said and then we add
them up okay
so that's a little bit of cheating but
it actually it's interesting to look
that code and it becomes
i'm going to do something here i'm going
to hide a bit of the code so i don't
want you to look at the gray stuff
that's
uninteresting stuff if you just read it
as if
you had this code the color part
it's very
very nice and clear to see what you do
there's some interesting aspects here
first of all
i mean this is pure functional call it's
just a function call
but
it kind of looks like imperative code
right if you look at it as
a series of statements
it's actually also imperative code with
a bit of a bonus because we know that if
if chain fails if any of these parts
fails then we will just abort
and not do the rest but we don't have
any
checks here right so this kind of
reminds me of another feature in c plus
plus that's
i don't even use here
i don't know if you can see it but
think about exceptions
so if with exceptions you can write a
try block with nice kind of linear code
no if checks and then if an error
happens you know you will jump
down to the catch part and deal with it
there this is a little bit like the same
thing except the error would be
percolate up to the caller instead so i
think that's an interesting observation
another interesting thing is
of course this call this is a pure
function call if you just
made this return of a function it will
always return the same
chain of parsers no side effects
that would be the case even if the
parsers themselves had side effects
because we're not actually calling any
parsers here we're just combining them
the
calling will happen later when we call
this combined thing
so
this is a great way to deal with side
effects in functional languages
and in in haskell for example if you
have a function with side effects you
cannot even call it in the normal way at
least
but you can't compose functions
and have them be called later so that's
a trick in haskell to deal with side
effects you sort of
compose the functions and delay the side
effects as long as you can
down to like the the last call in your
main that would be
where you set off everything but yes it
comes with this ugly syntax overhead and
there's no
great way to get around that in c plus
in haskell they invented a special
syntax for this and if you've seen in
haskell code you're probably seeing this
do notation
and this is how you'd write the same
thing in haskell and it looks kind of
similar right so you have this new this
special keyword in haskell do then you
just list your parsers if you're
interested in capturing the results you
can use this left arrow
uh and then just add them up at the
bottom and
call the function called return so two
things if you
if you haven't read read haskell code
before
this token integer that's a function
call in haskell so in haskell you don't
put any parentheses or commas you just
put name and arguments with white space
it's extremely terse
kind of hard to read in my opinion but i
guess you get used to it
so this parenthesis the bottom has
nothing to do with function calls it's
just evaluation order like in math you
add up those things and pass them as a
single argument to a function called
return
and return that's also thing in haskell
it confuses me a lot there's no return
keyword in haskell so name return this
is just a function and of course it's
the same as my unit function it just
returns a yeah that wrapped sum as a
thing
so
haskell doesn't need a return statement
because functions are just a single
expression so that's what it will return
but it has it has to be called return to
to work with this do notation
okay so many people looked at this and
of course people have proposed that c
plus
it would be really great if c plus plus
had something like the do notation then
we could do this nice functional
composition thing it could be useful in
many other cases and parsers
okay so is that a good idea or not
i don't know i potentially it's a good
idea
but i also have
very little hope that this will make it
into the standard at least anytime soon
there will have to be a lot of
underlying work to motivate it and
i just don't think it's high enough on
the priority list
all the standards committed to to do
that work so maybe you know a few
standards in the future but
yeah i guess we'll have to wait and see
but
uh
i'm actually also not very concerned
about that because it turns out we can
write
a parser combinator thing that looks
even nicer than
the left-hand version up on the top
and we don't need to use any new
features just c plus plus 20 and we get
most of the functionality of the do
notation
we just have to find out a little
different way to express this
so that gets us to the last point from
the beginning which is
applicative
parsing so
partial function application what's that
well
if you have a function in c plus plus
that just takes three arguments
of course you have to call it with three
arguments otherwise it couldn't compile
because how could it compute the sum
but if you worked in a functional
language like haskell you know that
in haskell you could actually call a
function and not pass in all the
arguments so what would happen is you
get back essentially a lambda that has
captured a pointer to the original
function and those arguments that you
passed it
and it will take as many arguments as
you didn't pass
so when you pass that with the remaining
arguments it ends up calling the
original function passing in
first the capture arguments and then the
rest
so that's partial function application
and you cannot do that straight away in
c plus because that's not the way
language was designed from the beginning
but we can easily emulate this we just
need to write
a simple helper function and i chose the
name p apply for this sort of mean
partial function application don't
confuse this with standard apply which
does something different
so it's just a function that takes
uh
it takes a function and a bunch of
arguments
and
then we can make a check is this
function invocable with those arguments
well if it is
then we're happy we can just invoke it
like normal
but what if it's fail
if that concept check fails
then we're going to assume that that's
because you didn't pass in all the
arguments so then instead we pass it
into standard bind front that's a new
function that was added in c plus 20.
so it's like standard bind but a little
less general
although it has a much nicer syntax so
you just pass it a function and a bunch
of arguments and it will return
a new function that has
capture everything and then you can call
that so that's what we want to do except
when we could just have called the
function with all arguments
note also that p apply here
it's using another new feature from c
plus plus 20 which is now you can write
generic lambdas with explicit template
parameters
so instead of auto parameters i have
used
name template parameters
which is a little bit scary now we can
use lambdas with all those four bracket
styles
but i actually think this is a nice
feature it simplifies language not by
itself but if you think about this
combined with that abbreviated template
syntax for free functions it sort of
unifies all these function
the ways you you can make template
functions
uh between lambdas and and three
functions so i think it's a nice
feature to make them more similar
uh
okay so with this now we have the option
if we have a function like sum3
we could call it
as normal just pass it to p apply
and call it once but we can also go the
other extreme if we have
this function with three arguments we
could call it three times with one
passing in one argument at the time
like at the bottom here
and that's known in functional
programming as carrying
which you probably heard about it's
named after haskell curry the same guy
that they named haskell after
theoretician who who came up with this
stuff
and now so we're armed with carrying in
c plus 20. and that's really great
because now we can write
a new parser combinator
so i use the last remaining bitwise
operator here the xor it looks scary but
it's really simple
you just call
your passive give it to parsers first we
invoke the first one call it pr the
result then we invoke the second one
call that qr
and then we pass pr and qrs
the parts things into p apply and that's
what we're going to return if both are
successful
okay so we're going to make a a helper
for this as well
so i like to call this sequence
so
sequence takes a function and a pack of
parsers it has to be as many parsers and
of the right value types so that we
could actually call that function with
the parse things
so
what we do is we we just use our
operator we call
return function into a parser with the
help of unit and then pass in the
parsers so it really hurts your brain if
you try to think about what this is
going to do when you call that big
return parser but essentially what we're
going to do is we're going to parse with
the unit of function which is going to
unpack the function then we're going to
partially apply one of the parsers
results
all the way to the end and at the end
we'll end up calling the function with
all those parsed things as arguments
and that's really nice because now we
can write this sum three parser we just
sequence
three calls to token integer the parse
things end up in the lambda on the top
as xy said and then we just add them up
and return it so if you compare this to
the do notation haskell it looks very
similar
except
the i mean the biggest difference i
guess is that the sum and ends up on top
instead inside of a lambda instead of at
the bottom
and of course those two returns you have
to remember they don't have anything to
do with each other but
this is really cool because
yeah this code is quite readable i think
and no so now some three parser and yeah
we can test it
yes we are christian here
oh interesting
you you spoke right over my head but
yeah let's discuss that
yeah i'm sure there are many other ways
we could do this but
uh
yeah yeah really cool actually if you
if you are interested you can do as an
exercise try to implement this operator
using chain it actually makes the
function looks a lot nicer and simpler
and it also kind of proves the chain is
a more general solution but it also
comes as a little there's a little
performance cost there so
but yeah something you can think about
and this is nice now we can go back and
rewrite some of our parsers so this sum
parser the first case where we use this
nested chain trick
we can instead rewrite this as a
sequence sequence of parser many parsers
we get the character and string
and we add them
or concatenate them on top you can do
this with most of the
use cases of shane i showed before not
all of them but most of them
right
so
it's a lot of code i know but think
about this now you can take all
basically all the code are shown you
just stick that in a header file or a
module file if you want to be really
modern
and you have
basically a complete parser combinator
library
maybe there's a bit more work if you
want to make it a great library but it's
all those things are general purpose
useful things
so now we're ready to actually
parse what we wanted to parse from the
beginning here mathematical expression
so we import this library of functions
we already know how the parse integers
we made a parser for that so now we just
need to parse expressions terms and
factors so we need to write three
parsers
and since they are referring to each
other we have to declare them first as
three functions and then define them
okay so we first declare them
pretty simple
so here's the first parser expression
what should it be is there parts a term
a plus sign an expression or a term
so it's a choice between a sequence
starting with term plus expression
we keep the term and the expression and
we add them
that's the result or if that fails it's
just we check if it's a single term
okay
same thing with term is a factor
multiplication sign term or a factor
so it's a choice between a sequence five
we keep the factor and the term we
multiply them
or it's a factor and finally
factor
it's a left parenthesis expression right
parenthesis or an integer
so again sequence we just keep the
expression and return it
or it's an integer
uh and here also it's not expressed in
the grammar but since this is a sort of
innermost
non-integer than thing then we could
actually get rid of all the white space
without the token
and we're done
so now we can parse
expression so here are some tests 3
times 2 4 plus 2 should be 14.
if you use parentheses it will
compute 18. if we try a negative number
it will work as well we could add some
redundant
white space and parenthesis it still
works if we give it something it doesn't
recognize like uh
subtraction we didn't implement that
then it won't it will get the first
factor but the res the rest of the
string
there will still be something left so
on the top level if it doesn't parse
everything you probably want to treat as
an error
and finally of course if you pass
like three as text it will also fail
so first example but it's a little bit
of a toy example right so we want to do
something cooler
yeah but first just for fun here's the
haskell code
and you can also observe here
it's uh yeah very very terse here's
using the do notation instead but this
is the same idea that curious operator
at the bottom that's the same as my pipe
operator so haskell has lots of these
strange operators to do different things
but you can see how nice it is it looks
it's pretty straightforward to go from
the
grammar to just writing the code
almost mechanical you might say so what
about parsing grammars themselves
so here's another example
this is uh this really interesting
example this is the original
uh this is from weird's original article
and it's the example he used to describe
the syntax of his language
and it's a cool example because if you
look at it
first of all it uses the different
syntactic constructs uh
but what does it describe well it
actually describes how to parse itself
so we have on top of syntax is a number
of productions so each of these lines is
in production so production is an
identifier equal size expression dot so
you have
identifiers production the equal sign
the expression and the dot at the end
and then you have an expression what's
that it's one or more terms separated by
the option
a term is one or more factors
a factor is either an identifier a
literal parenthesis expressions
parenthesis is just for evaluation order
again like just in math or it's an
optional expression or it's a repeated
expression
and finally a literal that's a non-empty
string of characters surrounded by
quotes
so he uses four quotes so you have the
quote with a quote as an escape symbol
so this is called escape and string and
then surrounded by quotes i mean it's
literal quote
uh
yeah um so this is actually
describes it all there's two things
missing there's no rule for identifier
but you can define that as maybe a
number or a letter followed by numbers
or letters or underscore or whatever you
like
and a character which is any character
in your character set so that's what the
item parser would understand
so
if you think about it so what if we can
just implement the parser for each of
these rules
or each of these productions
then we could parse grammars themselves
and we can parse them into any kind of
data structure we like
so what if we parse it into a data
structure and we equip the data
structure with some serialized function
that prints out something then we can
make it print out the source code for
a parser for this language
so we would have written a parser
combinator parser generator for other
parts of combinators
and even cooler if you give this
particular
input to that parser combinator it
should essentially print out print the
source code of itself
minus
a few things so that was really fun to
try
so here's just one example this is just
one of the parsers the production parser
so
identifier equal size expression dot so
i parse identifier equals expression dot
and i just keep the identifier and
expression and this
ast production these are your simple
structs that i created
that
makes my abstract syntax tree and then i
have a print function for this
and what happens if i give this
production function
the contents of the comment on top
and then print the resulting ast then it
will print the version on the bottom
which is more or less identical to my
function the only
thing you have to add is that what's
inside of this lambda what you want to
do with the result
and a few details like that
but that's really nice i think
okay so are we so now that we're armed
with this we can go in further and try
to implement some
big parser so what about parsing c plus
plus itself
okay so that's
quite a jump c plus plus is notoriously
difficult to parse
as you probably know it's not the
context-free grammar
there's many ambiguous situations
actually if you look in the standard
it's described in great detail how you
do how the par c plus plus there's
i think nine separate translation phases
so you go from
stripping white space and comments and
then the preprocessor expanding macros
and you deal with
templates and resolve ambiguous
suggestions so it's really complicated
it's nothing i would recommend doing as
a hobby project
i didn't try it
myself but i decided to try something a
little bit simpler
so i knew that in this book elements of
programming
at the end there's an appendix written
by sean parent and bjornis drew strip
and so what they do in this appendix
they
define a simple language and this
language is a pure subset of z plus plus
so it's missing a lot of features that
you even find in c
but it's not
a toy language it's a complete working
language you can actually compile it
within any old c plus compiler
and it was a language that was used to
implement all the code in this book and
if you know this book it has some pretty
sophisticated code in it it basically
explains how you implement something
like stl
so
it's a really instructive language it's
a great language if you want to write
like a book or paper and you want to
have show explain some algorithms
you could use pseudocode but it's cooler
to use real code but maybe you don't
want to people to have to understand all
of c plus so this is like a very
simplified c plus plus and i think it's
also instructive to see that they
managed to describe the whole language
in nine pages
this is about 200 times shorter than the
c plus plus 20 standard
of course it's not a fair comparison the
standard has to go into all these
technical details
this kind of glosses over this but i
think it's kind of interesting anyway
and schon parent he also wrote a
handwritten recursive descent parser for
this to test the code in this book
uh you can get that code on on his
github you can also actually get this
book for free nowadays you just go to
that link and download it check it out
for yourself
and
so this whole language
the syntax is described on these pages
it's 60 of these
productions in this vert's grammar
language
and
so we just need to implement six
departures of course if you have that
parsley generate that would help you and
but i was stupid i implemented this
before by hand
to see if it was possible and
here's one example this is just this is
a parsing a while statement so it's
while
uh parenthesis expression parenthesis
statement
so all of these functions are simple
parsers to write like this it's very
straightforward
all right so
i have a quick demo to show this
so what i did was i made a little tool
so this is just a toy thing
what you can do here is you can im you
can give it thing a single line
declaration in this
subset of c plus plus and check if it
syntactically is correct
so it's a test for my parser here so we
can try something like
if i make a function and a foo
takes an x and let's return
i know two types three
plus x
put some extra white space
that shouldn't be there okay does that
look like correct
syntax
oh yes i missed some cool oh i hope that
didn't break things
parsing successful okay looks okay
now i can actually format this code as
well kind of pretty print it so i have
just the serialize function for this
and this is like yeah compact
version so yes we see that it's correct
you can also format this in a json
format so this shows you the whole
abstract syntax tree this is kind of
thing if you're implementing a compiler
you would interested in seeing all this
you can also kind of simplify this tree
a bit so have like a prune function
takes away some redundant stuff
so now we see simplified tree here
so you see it's a declaration of a
procedure
it has a return type of in this is a
name which is an identifier called foo
and so on and so on and i also did some
constant folding here so if i format
this again
i simplified it so things like two terms
three becomes six now this is kind of
thing and compiler would optimize on
this level
so let's try something a little bit more
advanced so let's make a template
type name t we can even have this
language also has uh constraints or
concepts
so we can try
requires it looks a little bit different
than in c plus 20. let's pretend we have
a concept called integer
so you write it like that with
parenthesis in
the trick is you just can define this as
a macros that you that is compiled to
nothing
and then so it doesn't really do the
check
and then we make a struct
and let's make a data member tx
and let's try the constructor so we
should initialize maybe x to 42.
body of the constructor and the end of
the class
does not look correct i think so
yeah it parses
yeah it looks okay we have the json we
can prune it
show it again
yeah this time try an enum
no abc
oh it failed okay
what am i doing wrong
okay so you can see
anyway live demos
so i have this on github you can try it
out it's actually like if you think
about it if you want to write your own
toy compiler or like a c plus plus
interpreter or maybe you have your idea
for your own programming language like a
dielectric c plus plus or something this
could be a
little tool you can experiment and and
uh
yeah try changing it and see what and
yeah write some tools you get the
parsing
done for free so
yeah
should be
fun to use so we're at the end so i have
some takeaways here
some kind of positive
things in my mind is i think at least
the c plus plus is a language that
supports
a functional style of programming at
least in tactically i'm not missing a
whole lot
uh
but yeah we of course there could be
improvements also i think it's cool that
c plus plus it's not just
there's not just one functional language
the c plus plus there's kind of two so
you have your regular
runtime functional language
but you also have your compile time
functional language using concepts
a-list templates value templates and so
on
uh with every new version c plus plus
this i mean it's been known for a long
time that c plus plus templates is a
functional compile-time touring complete
language in itself
but with new features it feels more and
more like a natural language to use
some kind of neutral feedback i
think that you know it's
yeah there's many variants of callable
types in c plus plus which really
complicates things for beginners but you
know it's due to the long history of c
plus plus and they all have their uses
it's not like lambdas make classes with
a function call operator obsolete
sometimes you need them
and
and things like stud invoke help a lot
there
also of course i mean purely functional
c plus plus code will never be as
natural liters as haskell or language
was designed for functional programming
so if you really want to
work in this pure style maybe go ahead
and use a functional programming
language and not c plus plus
also there are some problems
first of all
you have to think about performance this
is c plus plus after all so
it may easily suffer
for example in c plus standard there's
no guaranteed tail call optimization
and so if you look at this
uh
do annotation in haskell you might think
oh that's just syntactic sugar that does
all these recursive like deeply nested
function calls but actually those
function calls are all tail call calls
so they are relatively easy to optimize
away by the compiler and haskell
guarantees that that is done so
even if you can think of it as
just you can just program in a pure
functional way but the compiler will
turn it into imperative style code with
ifs and whatnot but you never see that
in c plus plus there are no such
guarantees in general in the standard
i think there are some
some compilers have some intrinsics and
notation you can use but
before i think before if you want
something like the annotation in c plus
you probably first need to make sure
that you can guarantee tail call
optimization for performance so there's
a lot of this technical work that will
have to be done
uh also it's easy to accidentally do a
lot of extra copying of objects like all
these lambda captures i just capture by
value so some maybe you want to use like
perfect forwarding and move semantics
and think about things like that which
you don't need to think about in in
haskell for example
unfortunately also this is very very
hard work for the compiler the compiler
will really hate you if you try to write
the code like this
so i didn't notice this at first like
writing the number parser or the
the grammar parser it worked just fine
and i was using gcc 10 i believe
when i i started this but when i
implemented this
eop parser
i started noticing the compile times
were getting awfully long
and
when i was exactly halfway is at the
30th function
the 30th parser it started eating up all
the memory on my computer until the
compiler just crashed
so i thought okay
this is sound but yes i just decided to
try
switching over to clang instead and for
whatever reason clang does something
different i don't know what
but it still managed to compile it so i
very long compiled times but it still
worked and i managed to get all the the
second half of the parser done but it's
still like ridiculous compile times it
takes maybe half a minute and it's a
very small program on this computer
so we have to be aware that this does
not really scale that great i also tried
it in msvc 2022 recently
it also ate up all the memory and
crashed or failed so compiler writers
have some work to do if
they want to support this and if someone
knows a lot about debugging compilers
and can tell me why clang can handle
this and the others can't it would be
interesting to investigate
um
right
also i mean it
there if you think about there's all
this little lamb that's created so
try to compile it in debug mode you'll
get megabytes
and megabytes i think like 25 megabyte
binary for this very small program
really so
yeah
there are problems
okay so we're at the end here so i have
some links
uh linked to this talk you can find the
pdf you can also find the code
for this weird parser up parser and the
number part so you have all the code in
the slides
and there yeah feel free to use them for
whatever you like it would be fun to see
if uh
yeah you can come up with something cool
so please tell me i also included some
links to some people that you might
check out if you're interested in
functional programming in c plus plus i
think these are some some people from
the community that
are worth looking at so bartos and even
for example have written some great
books about functional programming c
plus plus
ben dean you might remember cppcon 2017
he did a keynote with jason turner
from cppcast uh called const expert all
the things
kind of a famous talk
where they showed how to so they ben had
used this uh uh parson combinator
technique to write a pure compile-time
json parser that you so you can use like
json strings like compile from switches
in c plus plus code so the focus on that
talk was const exper so they kind of
quickly went over the parser stuff but
you can look at the code and you look at
the talk you can see it's exactly what i
did
but it was in c plus 14. so you don't
really need z plus plus 20 for most of
this
uh but the code looks so much nicer now
than it looked back then
um
also like jonathan miller he has written
a parser combinator library called lexi
i think i have never used it it's the
same idea but it's a completely
different design
so for sure like many people have done
this before
and so if you want to learn more you
should definitely check out their
versions as well
and finally like sai brand has also
talked about this a lot and is one of
the champions of
of functional features in in future c
plus plus standards
so yeah that's
that's it so
any questions any comments ideas like
what do you think is c
functional language
yes no no
definitely yeah
right
so